我就不相信我们说存折还可以变出什么把戏
哇中抢女明星的风头呢
哇
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ I'm ready ♪
♪ Oh i'm ready ♪
♪ One two ♪
♪ Ready go ♪
♪ One two ready go ♪
我还想来个女明星吗
某老师
3D老师现场女明星的风头呢
好班司机jenny
Jenny
Jenny jy
呃南昌场就多加了热爱
大家又花了好些时间排练
♪ 女神天生就会陶醉 ♪
♪ 她想人间 ♪
♪ 谁问你成麻花 ♪
以为更多爱恋全世界被爱到热烈
想不到吧
那你猜不到
最好给我大声尖叫
你们有没有听见
这样子才会持续的有惊喜
在我旁边的两位一定要很有意识的在我前半部
因为我刚麦克风直接插在她头发
就是马尾
这样哈哈变卖家一摇怕就出来用
Ok ok the cu
哎呦
我怎么样
我是对的
很难得吗
只不过是十不对十对
这干嘛呢
怎么训练跑
那跑的好好
加什么歌呢
真的是不明白不明白不明白
为什么我这么放得开
小朋友有听过这首歌吗
小朋友哎嘿嘿嘿
这份爱呀
你是一生一世不会了解
♪ 我明白我明白啦 ♪
♪ 永远存在爱是否对儿有点怀念 ♪
可是我依依依依依依依
你已不在
I n b i g
下班喝一瓶茉莉蜜
让你心情甜蜜蜜
欢迎我们的音乐魔术师
为了这个演出
我大概准备了10年
啊哈哈
好起来了
哇哇哇哇哇
还有没有呢
哇还有不可能应该没有了吧
没有没有了吧
哦真的没有了
真的没有了哈哈谢谢姐姐
我真的练了10年啊
哇
哇哇外貌却可哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
欢迎展示480的王心凌
720的王心凌
高清画质的王心凌
啊哈哈哈
你的输出真的看起来有从壶的开始
到不到清晰的诶
牢记脑汁诶
我就不相信我们说存折还可以变出什么把戏
胶囊才进的
没有东西可以哈哈哈哈
不要再逼他了
不要逼他了
阿德勒阿德
我刚刚看到你香蕉好像欢迎来city party
♪ Cindy cindy cindy ♪
让你伤心
♪ 怎么可以心DYCINDY ♪
有快递
咿呀咿呀哟好吃
香蕉那味我整整吃了完快一首歌偷懒
我不可能拿着那一根钓网
我一定要把它吃完才可以跳
不然哪那个突然掉了
尴尬
我只能吃完了
还要买太久
谢谢谢谢姐
吃的香蕉特别好吃
你亲手剥的香蕉特别好吃
剥的嘞
他刚刚明明他刚刚明明就说吃太饱
♪ 就得要 ♪
♪ 好开心 ♪
♪ 我的爱造花天都由你来在一起 ♪
♪ 海浪海浪海浪浪耶 ♪
辛苦啦
南昌凯哥辛苦了
盛大的喉咙都反正休息
明天应该就好了
拜拜拜拜